Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Ark
The survival SHALL CONTINUE
AND I SHALL NOT BE THWARTED IN MY QUEST
because I've got a full belly
and apparently I've got full water too
because I think I just
tilted my head back and let the GODS FULFILL MY THIRST
and then, um
then I guess my energy is all good too
my warmth is not doing so bad
the only thing that I don't have its
fiber and it's the dead of night and
there's a weird glowy thing over there
I don't know what the hell that is but
I'm gonna go towards it
If theres other players im gonna go talk to them
they're talking about shoving keks in
each others mouths I don't exactly know
what that means but I'm gonna try my
But im gonna try my best to survive
that's all I know how to do and that's
all I will do
I've got some food I've got the will
got the wherewithal and all this kind of
pleased thank you i'm ready ready to
survive there anything that i can use
no?
alright fine. what's a list of what are
you
whoa there whoa hello
bye-bye I i wanna go dawgs you want to
go oh you're gonna go you're going to go
to hell after i beat the SHIT out of you
I don't know where you are but I'm
beating the shit out of the darkness
fireball the darkness you dead yet
goddammit haha ok you just woah hey
there's a lot of you alright okay
alright then you know what you're not
even worth my of my time
that's what I'm gonna say is my excuse is
that a bigger one
I don't know what that is but it looks
scary
hello hi how are you, who are you, are you tamed
what is gonna hold your bigger than
would you keep you just keep growing I
shit my pants because I was so scared
what the frick is going on here you
stuck
oh you're bigger than I thought you were
alright i don't know where i am and i
don't know what you're doing in that
rock but have fun mating with it i'm
sure it's enjoying it carry on who am I to
judge
I'm new here, okay then. hey goddammit come on
you still still on about that you want
you want to get some X3
I ate it in front of you that what you
want out
he know these assholes just won't leave
me alone so I don't know what that light
went the lights seem to have gone who's
there okay so I'm gonna go towards the
light and I'm gonna figure out what the
son of bitch is all about because if
it's something good for me i want to find it
and if its something bad for me i want to hit
head-on for get a chance to retaliate
thats looks scary
amber berry a fiber oh that's good
cool alright well that's something at
least
oh that looks that looks in Ken's it
seems to be on some sort of a fortress
out
whatever happened what what happened
Fred I died from what
but it certainly fall apart
I think someone beat the shit out of me
but I didn't even notice it
alright so people here a little little
bit rude if you ask me
all right i'm gonna respond and
apparently they killed me wherever they
are and that's really unfair i think
it's a good gucci the head maybe it just
maybe I still got the things that I can
crap yeah I'm still the same level that
I was and still the same guy I just need
to get some stuff again so they think
they can just toss me aside and i'll be
gone to the wind
I think not time to punch three so I get
back on my feet
object without fucking hell is happening
why am i under attack was attractive
I can't see shit at the mall while male
collapse or expand out here can't see
shit I'm blinded oh boy I'm blind I'm
blind I'm blind why am I blind that's no
good there's life is rough right this
way so mean what do you want to survive
just want to survive
okay i don't know what i'm heading wow
that's a big thing
what are you who your big they're all
your big I probably shouldn't yeah
Oh God blind again god dammit
apparently this is this is a goddamn
episode of death who shit where the Sun
please give me some sun damage boy i am
off him
I'm not where I should be there's a lot
of a lot of other creatures around here
laughing so my dad don't even do it
don't even try it don't try buddy don't
drive friend out ye like that i am
almost dead but you know what I can live
with that thing live with the fact that
i'm almost good she's oh I'm running out
of energy very rapidly
why is the shoreline not getting any
closer
oh god oh god oh god I've done group
tonight I'm gonna drown 0000 dough in
the darkness it was much further away
than it looks like it was
Oh No
oh no Ark survival evolved more like
Mark Martin bars help dead
you look cold brace death blow the hand
on me I'm gonna dating fast i fairly
swept across an entire ocean to try to
get down here i'm currently drowning dad
braid currently running out of oxygen
almost all I shit my pants says is the
river and I'm a-okay people thought that
I was down and out of my luck that
little vein know i was down and out of
nothing
i leveled up because I shit myself so
good swim across that son-of-a-bitch
hey you wanna you wanna fuck with me I
will fuck all over you all right level
on up i'm gonna get more men get more
movement speed hell yeah I like the
sound of that now i don't in that not
yet now you and I'm gonna hold off until
I actually know what I'm doing
what do I need for a torch Flint catch
need to hit a rock but the problem is I
can't see you goddamn rock is freaking
dark our hands she shit i'm a quick fix
or torch to harvest from this
oh ok so yes
ah-me berries I like it well I'm
grabbing up everything on the ground
hell yeah hell yeah
ok so i got berries huh they're gonna be
good for me i'm going to eat them they
better be good
they better be good all right but I'm
stay on the day is shining
hello son miss you gotta rock i'm gonna
hit well that's not good
I'm god damn it again with this shit you
wanna go toe-to-toe with me broken going
to consider going down I'm going down
but you're also gonna go down
out out out out just one fucking flip
off now this guy really hurts me bro
don't know i don't wanna die well i'm
out here I'm out of here
I'm out of here give it up give up bro I
knew the spear and I need to do is I
need to make a spear next who got to get
sick stuff I gotta do Larry I got 500k I
know how to get fiber now I know you
just spring madly and grab everything
that you can recklessly go whoo alright
i'm tired of thinking thinking I think I
lost it
yeah I think I lost it ok so like it to
stay here for a bit
that's why god damn it fuck you don't
know where you're not running for me run
you are no yes I thought you were gone
for me bro
I shit myself so cared you know the
Bears dark hand who apparently I made a
primitive stone and you don't know how
slow with that
yeah weirdo ok that by just calm down
here for a goddamn second I'm gonna kill
this monkey and what I need a better
thing to do that i'm going to make up
her right and then a church
alright and then i got these little
cherries and blueberries and I got narco
berries make you sleepy and I want to do
that I don't want to get lippy alright
but now I've got a spur so what's this /
I'm gonna drive it into the hearts of my
enemies like this monkey you have
valuable spurred news i brought my spear
talking about broke my spear fuck I'm
gonna get you you can run monkey huh
I don't care don't care don't care don't
care don't care don't care don't care
don't care don't care it monk most you
up
warm welcome to the bart monkey
Walbridge Oh you gonna chop it a lot of
things going to go super saiyan on me
know
well shit its body of the spirit into
the run behind you
I was trying to get meat from that I
wasn't trying to just send them in to be
a bit so it's going to actually get
something out of that anyway I didn't
work hard well I guess I'll up my
fortitude
that'll be nice i think i'll appreciate
that our sleeping bags sound good i'm
gonna do that a wall or roof our door uh
bad I'm we can do that or it can do that
get it okay
good job boots that scared I'm gonna do
that ok so i've got all about shit that
I can do I just need to get the
materials to be able to do it
he's got damn monkeys would stop what
you wanna go pop you're lucky you're
lucky this time
good thing I'm gonna go off and do more
resources and scream like a little baby
i need food real bad
I gotta go through the bush that's why I
got to get this bush bush but it's good
Bush Stanbury medal Barry who who is
going to be great
berries for me to unions Omar burden our
burden menswear justin bieber's off fast
god damn it back wrap
without friction road I ok I need to
himself going to hit for Valentine's
that advice you're giving me going into
the woods where you guys can't bother me
no more
you're bothering me that no haha gosh
alright anyway I got this type type down
me I got it
what you think I don't got this haha you
think you think I don't get that huh
you think I don't got this oh I got this
you just watch me got this now I know
and there's no stopping me
oh what's that I couldn't read a guide
dog that's not how market blocker
learned I learned from the Tyler what
are you learning to be with nice 30 2011
helpful in getting some more there we go
that's needed am Rockne Damron need am
wrong need am wrong I seem to be in some
sort of marshland now so I'm going to
Don the persona of my favorite animated
actor and channel my inner shrek here
and i'm going to build a home in the
swamp swamp shall be my home no one
shall be allowed in my swans my swamp is
where my law rains nobody shelf be able
to withstand the power of my swab and
anybody that dare dare try to get in my
swamp for you a fish-out-of-water you
look like a fish out of water maybe I
could grant you a swift yeah i'm going
to get a pic i can make an pants and a
shirt i can be civilized and wear
clothes and beat the shit out of you
what's that you can't fight back that's
my favorite type of enemy tom tom tom
drum drum drum drum drum drum drum drum
drum drum drum going to eat some berries
in the middle of this little hungry when
I'm lumping helpless fish don't beat the
shit out of me is just gonna happen you
better just lay down all over come up
there we go
give me that thing up and get that fish
meat Oh break yet another one over there
hey don't worry about i whistled
apparently i got a beard
whoa i'm becoming America's do that i'll
look good baby I just want this to
appear my friend i denied such beautiful
green eyes beautiful so i need to you
get back you're going to make another
one eventually everyone although I level
up and it's kind of stays consistent
throughout it that's that's not too bad
not bad
the worst thing in the world yep you
that ye need more stone for you and me
right the only thing my swamp does not
provide and it provides a lot don't get
me wrong it provides me almost
everything that I could but we need for
my adventures why you need to give me
rock
I'm yeah obviously could rock quality
you smell it you smell quality in Iraq
good rock and I thought what could not
provide rock and provide the best rock
the richest run the most never drop this
from my ancestors user add these four
miles
Megan spongebob reference we can do it
guys I'm doing it would think the living
at swap it's the best place to level you
want to talk about the reject like the
dog wants to build a base it's my boma
swap is my love a good thing I gotta
back off
oh that's convenient you can just
president little craft
oh you can repair it oh that's even
better than having a new 1i guess haha
do that Bob do okay i'm getting weighed
down a bit i need to do pile of hitting
something I'm mine at the bottom
thank you also these thorny he's hurt me
if I were going through now you get to
what way with a buddy
alright you carry on now you gonna be my
friend that you will bet you will
hell yeah my pants ready are my pants
ready that they are your legs all I'm so
handsome
all I'm dapper oh look at me I'm gapper
oh hell yeah you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna make a match foundation i'm
going to make a wall i'm going to make a
door i'm going to make a roof i'll make
another wall i'm going to make a door
fram and then I'm gonna make a stone had
chat and then I'm up I'm going three
that coming to you know I'm doing
surprising living dang dong good for
dying twice and getting to the point
where everybody could get you basically
in the game about trying
no I took me two episodes to do it and I
did it so with I'm proud of myself
you guys probably are but hey i am doing
ok I'm learning I'm learning as I go and
I think that is something that ever that
is a giant snake oh my god that is a
chance Nick yeah okay maybe it's a swamp
and maybe don't come near me you snitch
you slither on out here you bastard
alright so this seems like you're
getting up places any to start laying
the foundation down who don't like these
runners ok anyway we're going to do my
thing hopefully they don't bother me to
the foundation the walls the door the
door fram the whole ok you carry on
she sums people are not happy here
anymore fortitude
I'll get that stuff later I've got down
at the stake so my torpidity my
torpidity is rapidly drained 00 make why
next please i'm still doing so good
ok i could let me alone though know or
do not come after people come back to be
going back in this month you can break
away from you you get up get up get up
get up come on get up why am I just on
the ground
well I mean I got bit by snake obviously
you something
no no yeah yeah yeah oh oh they're both
being the shit out of me
nothing yet i'll be right back
you right back guys believe that they
played all god awful truth I friend how
you doing ok I've got my pants back I've
got my shirt back
I can cover up my gross body and then
what the hell is that one of missing so
I can't build here because apparently
I'm too close to an enemy Gators
something like that I think that's
probably the gate as big as gave so I
don't know what the hell that big wire
is but I'm going to keep going a little
all my god it's the create wall holy
shit
no I'm going to hear you don't want to
be here
what the fuck what happened
goddammit you pulled my light out why
oh alright everything's fine be breast I
can make this just got to make my god
damn bass gonna make this right here huh
Oh food
yes oh let me make it here haha oh yes
oh that's oh it's so good up and then
yes yes and then ate adore even oh and
then I have a roof i know i do yes I do
it it's destiny
Oh a roof over
oh I have a home i have a home for
belong to call my own
I've got it made it and I think that's a
good place to end the second episode of
Ark know you worry I've got a lot more
to do you see those empires of there
will be worshipping me here god they
will erect monuments to my glory that
roof it's just the key
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for cheering me on
like a million in the comments down
below let me know you think i'm doing
and what my prospects after the future
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
*Markiplier's outro music*